we're over the hump so I'm skipping the
intro and we're diving straight into
part 11 Door and Window schedules now
this one's a little bit nerdy and we're
gonna try and keep it relatively simple
so that everybody can work their way
through this and make sure they can
replicate for themselves first of all
let's jump back to our ground floor plan
and actually Define what we're talking
about what we what we need to do is
identify each one of our doors and our
windows in our project on both levels
where to identify them with some sort of
marker so let's select the front door
it's typically where we start with our
door window schedule and we generally
work in a clockwise pattern so if we
started our front door we can work our
way around the building and then come
back command T opens up our settings and
then down the bottom you're going to see
classifications and properties the first
thing you need to check is that your
door is actually set to door if it's not
set to door it's just not going to show
up on any of your door and windows
sketch next you want to give it an ID
tag you want to call it what you
specifically want to call it for me I
like to have my door as d01 if it's a
sliding door S01 if it's a pivot door
p01 so forth Windows a kind of similar
concept w01 moving forward in this case
it is a non-load bearing element it is
positioned on the exterior not the
interior doesn't make too much of a
difference in our door window schedule
but it's nice to have there we can
either go through and update all of our
individual elements here in our
classifications and properties to
backload into our schedule or we can
create a very unique Special schedule so
first of all let's hit that ok button
let's come all the way around find the
second door open that up repeat our
process d02 non-load bearing
and exterior pressing okay last but not
least we have our door zero three which
we also want to change in name for the
purpose of this we also want to
introduce all of our windows so let's
start at the front door go to
classifications make sure that it's on
the window change that to Windows zero
one position
exterior structural non-load bearing
okay we can go around repeat that for
all of these windows on the ground floor
so I'll quickly go and do that now and
now that we've got around tagged all of
our windows with the correct label that
we are happy with we can go and add a
door or a window tag so if you come
across to your labels on the left hand
panel you're going to find your label
tool you can open up the label settings
and go through a series of available
properties for you personally I love the
4d1 it just makes sense but again not
available to everybody the easiest ones
to use is the property label or the
opening label if you want a little bit
more detail otherwise you can scroll
through test these out and see what you
like so as an example property label
let's make that all black so it's
relatively easy to understand if you
want a pointer or not it's completely up
to you guys personally I don't see so
much value in the pointer but if you
turn the pointer off you'll see a leader
line pops back into place so you're
going to come into your symbol label
custom settings come across find leader
line untick that press OK and then you
will have your first door and window
schedule tag so simply by duplicating
that I can select each individual window
click on the window to create the tag
and then drag it where I'd like it to be
positioned in this documentation package
and then you go around add them to all
those windows and make sure you're happy
with interior doors you can do very much
the same thing however I would change it
to ID 0 1 so you know that an interior
door is an interior door not
specifically a exterior door if you want
to go ahead repeat those same steps on
the Upper Floor you're most welcome to
it is going to be identical from what
you've just done on the lower floor take
note that these labels can be done for
anything you can use them for wall
schedules you can use them for floor
schedules you can use them for basically
anything that all we want to do now is
come all the way across to our right
hand panel I'll extend it out just so
you can see a little bit more we then
want to come over to our main project
map scroll down until we find schedules
open up our elements tab which is going
to hold our door list you can double
click on the door list you're going to
have a very simple Door and Window
schedule
now you've got a door list and you've
also got a door schedule which basically
creates all of these doors automatically
for you highlights them provides them in
elevation gives you the color from the
outside gives you the color from the
inside and much much more when we look
at this door and window schedule it's
relatively complicated for instance from
room and two room often isn't required
if you have a door label you know
exactly where it is and you can map it
back to that information so how do we
adjust this how do we edit it well the
first thing you want to do is come
across to scheme settings in the top
right hand corner and in scheme settings
you can click through any of these the
door list the window list the door
schedule or anything you need for us
we're talking about door schedule right
now so we don't want from Zone we can
remove it we don't want two Zone we can
remove it quite happily the quantity I'm
happy with I know I've only tagged one
as door zero one the door Leaf is very
important the width the height the seal
height and the head height all all
absolutely critical the plan preview
isn't actually that critical so I tend
to actually remove the plan preview
personally and only leave some form of
elevation the frame width the framed
thickness are relatively important if
you didn't change them you have to
change them in the actual door settings
moving across to our frame Outside
Inside Leaf color and glass they are
also relatively important especially as
you document more and more into
construction you can make sure every
door is painted exactly as you need it
to be without going over the top and
trying to create some sort of ridiculous
schedule I'm going to press OK for this
in just a second to showcase the fact
that everything changes and
automatically adjusts across if I
continue to scroll across to the right
hand side open up my scheme settings
again I can then see some more details
so Leaf thickness handle height handle
offset from Edge again some of these
things are relatively important but in
reality not that critical you if I was
doing this myself I would adjust if I
was doing this myself I would adjust the
leaf thickness the handle height and the
handle position as well as the handles
up in line with the frame thickness
because we're jumping from thicknesses
and specifications to Colors so we want
to group elements as best as we can hold
Open Door device is a very useful
feature as is the fire exit as is the
hardware set and lock set auto close and
opening notes so I'll leave all them for
the time being if you double click on
number of hinges it is a default text
box so you can simply just type in three
hinges press OK and it will
automatically populate with three hinges
the glass can be changed directly from
this space noting that it will
automatically change the material as
well you can also tick or untick these
fire exit boxes and your hardware and
lock and Auto close all are the same
notes would be Pro normally for a
special item if you needed anything
outside of the ordinary or that was
missing if you have something that is
typically shown on all of your doors and
windows that is critical something
potentially like a weather seal let's
jump back into our scheme settings and
we can add some Fields so for instance a
door seal is a non-existent and not
available for us so what will we do in
that instance well let's press OK let's
jump to our help menu and let's type in
manager if we come across two
classification manager open up our
classifications go to elements go to
openings find door and select on our
door you'll see there is a number of
different elements available to us all
we can then do is hit our property
manager tool find our openings press
plus and in this property name I'm
simply going to call it door seal things
I press OK that door seal is going to be
created at the bottom of that list now
from there we can take a little bit step
further we can change it from a string a
number or all sorts of different things
the quickest and easiest way is most
likely an option list and then that
option list is just a simple drop down
menu what do we want do we want to
weather weather seal do we potentially
want an acoustic seal do we need a fire
seal or potentially we just want not
applicable press OK press OK press OK
update our scheme setting once more and
we can actually search
see you this time openings door seals
double click on it it is added right
directly to the bottom I'm just going to
adjust that above our notes press OK
door seal we can see it is now available
to us but what I've done is missed a
critical step so what we need to do help
come back to property manager and
instead of going to our value definition
up the top where we typed in weather
seal we want to change our availability
for classifications simply change it to
custom find outdoor tick the door box
and press OK it will add that to the
schedule on the right hand side finally
we press OK and it's going to allow us
to actually Define out where the seals
are acoustic SEALS or even our fire seal
so if there was fire seal it is a fire
door we definitely don't want it to hold
open in a fire instance Hardware we can
list it locks we can list it and notes
so forth if you wanted to go ahead and
change the hardware to some sort of drop
down menu you to something that you are
continuously using throughout the day
throughout the week you can do that as
well just like we created this door
schedule you can do the exact same thing
with the windows schedule go through
adjust it exactly how you like it make
sure it has all the parameters you need
or don't need and hopefully by the end
of this video you know a lot more about
arcad we're continuing through this
arcad course that's all for this episode
like always I'll see you next Monday